[Music]
it'd be more active news Oh submitted by
tuxedo max from Sailor Moon is that is
that fix you don't know oh yeah a stupid
cartoon anyway a new study claims that
sitting down too much is worse than
smoking yup I agree I read that [ __ ]
that's why my back's all [ __ ] up
alright so I'll just start smoking more
I get it smoke coming up my back soft or
I usually would smoke this like I guess
study about depending on how much you
sit like your lifespan shuang's
it does but what about all this [ __ ]
with the [ __ ] cigarette and they
[ __ ] through the water and then it
like sucks and all the smoke and there's
all this starlets black [ __ ] in your
lungs that sounds pretty warm they're
both bad but to me it's like obvious
that that's worse than smoking doesn't
it I mean it feels like it like sitting
down more lifestyle they're saying it's
worse for your health than smoking
diabetes and heart disease
well cuz that [ __ ] causes all of that
true it does you know what's odd now if
I don't move around I just I feel really
weird yeah I used to like just waiting
for the day to end this is nice but now
I have to I have to move we're all you
know run died that's the thing it's like
a big mental thing too is that grind you
know yeah it's not just like I'm an
active dude but like I just have to cry
you know like you get a sense of urgency
when like you know you're trying to make
some [ __ ] happen yeah you know that's
the main thing well a lot of people
don't have that - yeah it makes me feel
odd if I don't like even like when I
extend my vacation too long I'm like
this is weird right yeah I gotta keep
doing something I mean I have a standing
desk now which is tight I have one - it
broke though so no just a medium desk so
the buttons broke to go up and down oh
it's a very odd height right it's like
right here at my chest laughter alright
and I'm too cheap to get a new desk so
probably is what's wrong with it it
broke the motor broke I think it's kind
of a little bit of a novelty thing too
though with those things yeah
you know I mean 100% I love this what
standings not good either yeah use
that's a reactive period I love showing
people that [ __ ] too
impresses people yeah like I like put
the wheat here and I'll bring the wheat
up to me to roll it I feel like you
don't do what the homies I feel like you
only do it with girls I definitely do it
would be like yo check this out you
wasted my time for this I thought wasn't
that get some dick yeah so there's a
study conducted by cardiologist at
Cleveland Clinic and it was published
recently and so the studies surveyed
roughly one hundred and twenty-two
thousand participants who went through a
series of treadmill workout between
early 1991 in late 2014 and so they were
able to record individual fitness levels
the patients and then follow up to
predict mortality rates and so they were
looking to record the benefits of
exercise and fitness on mortality rates
and so they were saying according to
this data that lack of cardiovascular
fitness is a huge risk factor for death
and lack of exercise is actually worse
and being a current smoker and also too
I was reading this [ __ ] or like if you
do an hour of like workout it's super
intense but then you sit for like 12
hours straight that's also just as bad
like what you want to do is kind of take
breaks walk around keep moving
throughout the day and if you can like
walk places it's that's more I guess
healthy like breaking up you're sitting
and standing and and and having variety
and stretching yeah yeah it must be
really healthy cuz you're a little I
can't sit still for [ __ ] so I don't like
sitting but then when you're in the zone
though you lose track of time that's
true that's just yeah that's the thing
with me it's like doing music like being
in the studios like that's you're
sitting there for hours listening to
[ __ ] you know what I mean and I think
that shit's unhealthy like I'm not
necessarily like a sitter who'd just do
that kind of [ __ ] but it's like you kind
of have to do it make sure the work yeah
it's like focus but time goes by fast in
there do it it does
ridiculous it's unhealthy lifestyle to I
thinking when you creatively focus on
anything you forget to eat you forget to
do a lot of [ __ ]
just zone yeah so very like conducive to
being an alcoholic yeah
you have the pastime it's true yeah
loosen up - I drink a lot for sure
that's that's the biggest thing for me I
don't like really dude I got a little
even smoke weed that much anymore like I
used to when I was a teenager [ __ ] but
it's been like a long time I don't smoke
or nothin but alcohol is like one thing
that's still so socially accepted
anywhere yeah that's all like always
there you know [ __ ] stuff just Duda and
I Paul when I was in San Jose we had
like that you know that regular handle
of Jameson we had the big but you know
the [ __ ] huge went we finished that
[ __ ] in the whole night oh my god just
you - yeah yeah because I had a bounce
so we had to record five tracks within
two days I didn't know any of the music
cuz I did everything so I had to just go
in there and just get smashed drugged
and just knock them out cuz if not I
would overthink it so we just had to do
it and if it didn't sound good the next
day I just had a record variety tap into
that theta state I was doing so much
Davis and I quit Jamie now oh really
yeah I just drink vodka sodas I do new
vodka sodas for eight months now I'm
drinking out Jamie why'd you switch off
the tips cuz it was like I was like why
have I been drinking game is to pretend
here you know I mean like we've been
drinking so much of it I'm like I not
for that snapped out of I was like why
am i drinking does this I've been
switching over to a tequila yeah a lot
of good I think that's happening a lot
of people are kind of like you jump down
on this tequila wave right now you know
why you hate tequila because you're
having [ __ ] like patron and [ __ ] you
need to have like no I hate to kill her
because that was the first time that I
got smashed and I was very young and it
was traumatic I'm pretty sure you had
bad tequila though cuz if you have your
like
Reposado all this other [ __ ] like
different types they taste way
difference I'm gonna even taste like
water
no but tequila comes from the state of
the place where I got smashed this is
bad it doesn't mean it's all good or bad
true but I mean it's from this the
Orangemen from the source so there's a
lot of origin play that is good would
you drink la water gato is good like
this water from a lake it's like a
high-quality tequila like a bougie
tequila I puked on that Jose Cuervo and
I said never again
that was me for Jack Daniels
oh man I'll never [ __ ] go near Jack I
don't ever have Jack click straight up
yes it was always Jack and Coke shot to
my odj Zoe's ambassador for Jameson oh
is it a joke no he's dead as the
Ambassador he just like announced that
yesterday but but it's cuz like he's
constantly when he DJ's he's like always
pounding Jameson says all his Instagram
photos in like I wish we could figure
out a way to like walk more or work
outside
maybe I'll just be a construction worker
or something I don't know what in the
hell just walk I do walk but I want to
walk more and just walk over eight hours
like you know to me like if you if
you're outdoors and you're working all
day that's a lot of like movement in the
Sun just outside be a farmer bono you
have all your meetings walking walking
the bunch of people following if we need
someone caring like a whiteboard longer
ones like the whole time that's their
[ __ ] job then that's a good idea
swimming is like the best cardio right
like it doesn't really damage your knees
and [ __ ] yeah riding it does actually
wear that wear out your knees I suck at
swimming I just float like David when I
swim I can't do it for a workout I get
lazy I just that is a hard ass workout
that's a tough workout because if you
stop you're drowning especially if you
like in the ocean are some deep bass
water you can just stop halfway try to
swim before working out like laps and
stuff it is [ __ ] brutal bro yeah yeah
I do feel like I can go longer though
cuz I I stay cool like the water keeps
my it's more your breath I don't like it
because I like the feeling of being
drenched with sweat so because I'm
already wet I'm like [ __ ] I ain't doing
[ __ ] here even though my muscles are all
[ __ ] up I'm like I'm putting a floor
it's like walking dude please walk I
feel like I've always been kind of
working out on that walking or running a
fast Walker
I didn't bring my walking shoes I think
mr. underwear will do better really like
cathartic though because I walk every
day so it's like that the biggest thing
I ever did
what's cathartic about it you don't
think about [ __ ] you could just blank
out and you just go it's almost like
meditation now it is meditation yeah it
doesn't make you heave it doesn't make
you like super tired but you're still
burning an absorbing amount of calories
just going outside and walking for
[ __ ] miles and a lot of the times to
people like oh I love listening the
podcast will do it as you walk ya know
what's the podcast give me through my
runs the easiest yeah for I thought was
MS ik but the one I get lost in
conversation I just keep running
oh [ __ ] all done right now listen to
like like the Joe Rogan podcast when I
start my walk because I didn't I
actually don't even count the time that
I walk but it always ends up being about
an hour which I didn't realize cuz I
might listen to a podcast and that's
thing you know I'm done and that's how I
lost most of my weight anyways we're
just walking I didn't [ __ ] that's sure
you don't have to run I just got a wad
got me that's fine people think you have
to like be heavily breathing and all
that [ __ ] but most people don't even
[ __ ] walk in LA yeah like my biggest
thing that I learned is it's not about
intensity it's about frequency so you
could work out intense two times out the
week or you can work out seven times
moderately it's true you know what's the
biggest difference just like you have to
continue it that's exactly what that
study said you sit like straight but
then you work out for one hour it's yeah
it's it's still [ __ ] up when I first
started exercising I got coach told me
as long as you're moving more than your
rest days we're good so like people oh
how many days should I work out you
could be light for workouts a week but
at least you train for days out of the
week and you can rest three but if
you're resting more than you're working
out then you're gonna be sedentary when
you're having fun though it doesn't feel
like a work out it just feels like a
play house I had a personal trainer but
I [ __ ] scammed me
I paid it in advance because he had a
better deal that way it is disappear
like no are you talking are you taking
stabs that bar right now because I
remember to stretch the [ __ ] out of Doug
do it will relax pause so embarrassed
about that like how do you get scab a
personal trainer i straight-up got
scammed from a person who is he or she
like it recently happens I don't want to
go and do it
oh ok was it the same dude that's next
to sip the [ __ ] whatever is something
fitness dude
[Music]
[Music]